una trágica fuga de oxígeno en india
cuando el país lucha contra la escasez
del preciado gas de los hospitales al
menos 22 pacientes de coronavirus
conectados a respiradores fallecieron
por la interrupción del suministro
nástic el mismo día que la nación
asiática reporta el aumento diario de
contagios más altos del mundo con casi
300.000 nuevos positivos y 2023 decesos
nos está resultando difícil dar atención
o tratamiento personal a los pacientes
afectados ya que nos estamos quedando
sin oxígeno los medicamentos como el
rehén decidir y algunos fármacos no
están disponibles y el oxígeno ha sido
la principal escasez de los hospitales
indios han alcanzado su punto de ruptura
ante el virtual incremento de los
contagios durante la segunda ola de la
pandemia en la capital nueva delhi con
20 millones de habitantes el 65% de los
pacientes en estado grave tienen menos
de 40 años y las autoridades sanitarias
dijeron que les queda suficiente oxígeno
para menos de 24 horas y entonces
refuerzan las medidas de seguridad ante
los
de saqueos derivados de la desesperación
ciudadana
los médicos enfermeras los celadores y
el resto del personal sanitario trabajan
las 24 horas del día por encima de
nuestra capacidad como van a poder
instalar las bombonas si se las llevan
no se sabe que necesita oxígeno y quién
no
en menos de dos semanas india duplicó la
tasa de positividad al 17% y ya supera
los 15,5 millones de contagios una
propagación que los especialistas
atribuyen en parte a la doble variante
del patógeno más contagiosa pero también
en las laxas restricciones de los
gobernantes que llevaron a creer
falsamente a muchos ciudadanos que
habían derrotado la pandemia